alors loisne il ya plein de gens il ya
plein de tweets ya plein de réactions
sur les réseaux sociaux qui nous disent
qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé la pauvre
loana alors luan est ce que tu peux nous
raconter c'était mercredi dernier était
encore en vacances c'est ça tu étais
avec une copine j'étais avec une amie à
strasbourg en vacances à côté de la
meinau et on a voulu aller se baigner
dans un lac du poumon est habillé tout
simplement mon jeans t-shirt et jeans
t-shirt a vu également comme la cua de
cool quattro keynes et sa tranquille
peut on aller vers le lac et de là il ya
un jeune homme qui nous a interpellés en
scooter vous nous demandez de numéros de
téléphone direct pour nous complimenter
et juste après après après c'était venu
au téléphone et nous réseaux sociaux on
a ignoré au début donc là au début vous
répondez pas non au début on répond par
ailleurs parce qu'on a l'habitude
malheureusement ça t'arrive saut à ces
papas de à strasbourg ça devait arriver
plus souvent qu'en région parisienne
bizarrement donc je pense ça dépend des
régions aussi mais oui ça m'arrive
malheureusement pour contrebande ton
numéro parfois tout ça et après tout on
donne d'ordinaire plus ou moins lourds
de donc là tu ignores tignes au virginia
vous l'ignorez ensuite ces belles
personnes persistent du coup on commence
à lui répondre qu'on est pas intéressé
que voilà on va être frustrant qu'ils
entrent toutes les deux est allé au lac
se baigner et puis c'est tout hyper 6 6
pers et s'ils persistent bout de cinq
minutes commence à vous insulter ou
aller au bout de cinq minutes il
commence à nous traiter green dire c'est
parce que vous êtes des [ __ ] que vous
refusez mais avance à aucun moment il
s'est dit non c'est juste parce que tu
es un gros lourd non mais bon et du coup
à ce moment là la pause et son scooter
et s'est avancé vers moi et de là il m'a
mis un premier point à la figure mais là
tu vas peut-être pas répondu bon si je
lui dis dégage et je lui dis que ça
devenait oppressant et qui se rendait
pas compte ce que ça faisait d'être une
femme est ce que désolé et je lui ai dit
qu'il se rendait pas compte ce que ça
fait d'être une femme de se faire au
prix mais comme ça tous les jours dans
la rue que ça devenait lourd ça devenait
redon dedans que quoi qu'ils n'ont cédé
non quoi moquette il restait plutôt
cordelle tu veux juste expliqué le truc
cordiale au bout d'un an je suis un peu
énervé l'âge le mac qu'elle a besoin de
6 à 16 ans alors donc là et delilah
possession scooter et puis est venue un
premier point dans la figure puis un
deuxième puis un troisième puits
voilà puis jusqu'à ce que je puisse te
bouger en fait en fin de compte
et voilà on voit des photos c'était jour
de change arrivée à l'hôpital et m'ont
appris si on est pris à mon ami tout de
suite en fait je n'ai même pas eu le
temps de réagir ni quoi que ce soit et
puis
du coup elle aussi elle a été frappée
elle a été vue et deux coups elle a été
mise au sol enfin il y avait personne
autour de vous cc mais personne n'a
réagi anne mahrer chaîne raji personnel
j avais des pères de famille avait des
familles entières des femmes des hommes
des enfants des groupes de jeunes
personne n'a réagi alors là la route
quand elle raconte la scène thierry on a
vraiment l'impression qu'ils sont isolés
c'est ça c'est ça exactement dans quoi
il y avait beaucoup de monde autour
oui il y avait vraiment c'était une
personne donc en fait y avait du monde
dans le parc avant qu'on arrive aulas
qui donc est donc comment vous avez fait
pour pour vous sortir de là je me
demande encore comment j'ai fait très
sincèrement parce que j'ai cru ce jour
là que j'allais mou et je me suis va
sortir un couteau il va me planter et
c'est fini et c'est au final ce qui
s'est passé c'est que bout d'un moment
et arrêter nous frapper puis il a dit
nous laisser partir mais au final en
fait on a commencé à partir il est venu
en scooter derrière avec un ami qui a
pris le volant et il est et il était
tout seul au début puis après il ya un
de ses amis qu'il a rejoint où son grand
frère je ne sais pas encore à l'heure
actuelle et de la le père cette personne
a appris le scooter et conduit est en
fait c'est de prendre mon sac par
derrière et moi étant parisienne j'ai
quand même des bons réflexes au niveau
des vols ont réussi à tenir et ils ont
essayé nous racketter en fait on a dû
s'excuser s'excuser nous d'avoir mal
parler
j'ai dû m'excuser m'excuser m'excuser
m'excuser m'excuser faire que ça et puis
il supplié nous les étudiantes et en ce
sens là selon la coutume et non je
n'étais pas en soi on a vu les images
en fait c'était en début je me suis dit
ça va en fait ça va parce que ce juste
gonflé gonflé et la copine mon ami elle
ça l avait rien physiquement elle avait
juste alors elle avait des faux sont
réels avaient des choses on va racheter
mais on s'est dit c'est ça va c'est en
fait moi tout de suite j'ai senti une
douleur au niveau de l'oeil
je suis une ans il ya un truc qui va pas
éclater excuses à m'excuser auprès des
deux voilà c'est ça et puis au final ils
ont une longueur ajustions que juste
rentrer chez nous on fait rien au bout
d'un moment j'ai essayé de sortir de mon
téléphone fois c'est de le prendre en
photo
mais en fait au moment où j'ai sorti mon
téléphone il m'a tout de suite cramé il
m'a dit des lilas s'est levé le poing il
a dit tu fais quoi là tu fais quoi là et
je suis pas je regarde juste d'atteindre
mon visage et j'ai pas pu prendre de
photos malheureusement ma finale
malheureusement oui et non parce qu'il
était déjà bien connu des services de
police donc d'accord alors donc fracture
du plancher orbital
c'est ça tu as dû être opéré lundi opéré
l'anzhi c'est ça et on voit que la ses
loyers bien bien il va être libre il a
été interpellé le jeune mais c'est ça le
sport
alors identifié identifié et interpellé
il a été attentif et donc tu as été donc
tu as été la police tu là c'est ça la
dcri j'ai été à la police qui m'ont mais
adorablement accueillis je tiens à le
remercier mille fois je sais pas si on
voir l'émission mais je remercie mille
fois de ce qu'ils ont fait donc qui va
directement tu rentres chez toi d'abord
tu vois tes parents tu payes tes parents
n'ont en fait mes parents n'hésitez pas
et strasbourg à toi c'était pas avec
strasbourg avec moi c'est à dire que je
viens on va se réfugier dans un auchan
avec mon ami et de l'est en fait on
voulait juste prend des glaciers rentrer
chez nous et en finale il ya un mec de
la sécu qui est venu nous voir et qui
nous a dit
mesdames qu'est ce qui vous arrive qu'on
si vous êtes dans cet état et puis de là
je me suis effondrée au sol
j'en pouvais plus j'ai plus de force et
de la police est arrivée les pompiers on
à aller à l'hôpital
puis j'ai été je suis sorti de là le
soir même de l'hôpital et puis je suis
retourné en région parisienne dès le
lendemain pour faire des radios d'accord
et donc tu arrives au commissariat donc
tu tues le raconte son histoire
c'est ça je le raconte ce pas ce qui
m'est arrivé est bas ils ont été mes
hivers compréhension et j'ai même pas
les mots pour décrire à quel point ils
ont été bienveillants adorable vraiment
très protecteur très compréhensive très
professionnelle avec moi et je l'en
remercie mille fois parce que je me
rends compte que la police a vraiment un
rôle très important au sein de la
société et que ba 102 malgré tout ce
qu'on peut dire de ba 102 en fait ce
serait l'anarchie totale
donc je suis à leur merci mille fois
pour ce qu'ils ont fait alors là comment
t'as quand tu as su qu'il était connu
des services de police mais parce qu'ils
m'ont dit de nouveau connaître ta
famille 24 photos et il était sur 11 des
photos noms au palmarès 16 ans donc ils
ont identifié désormais hockey ce qu'il
va se passer
alors alors justement parce que là là
moi j'ai envie de savoir et on va
revenir sur la sphère politique voilà
parce que la voie la mine de rien on va
par les douanes de son maçon de son état
psychologique est là dans un instant
parce que physiquement je pense que ça
va s'arranger
ça va s'arranger voilà c'est sûr mais
psychologiquement je peux vous dire que
lohan elle a été beaucoup plus touchés
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour un gars
comme ça alors justin entrée de débats
je voulais dire simplement alwan qu'elle
ait eu raison d'aller porter plainte
c'est important parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de jeunes comme ça qu'ils se font
frapper souvent et qui ne vont pas
porter plaine donc l'important c'est
d'abord d'être allé voir la police et
d'avoir porté plainte c'est excellent et
c'est bien que la police ait fait son
boulot pas toujours évident pour eux
mais là c'était une bonne chose dont il
va être tout simplement traduit en
justice
oui mais il risque ont bien failli
risque il risque faisant seize encore à
mon avis l'établissement pour mineurs
pourraient encore bien qu on se passera
rien c'est tout le problème c'est juste
une amende pour les parents risquent à
16 ans mais le problème c'est que les
jeunes de 16 à 20 ans a bien sûr été
évolue maintenant oui les jeunes
16 ans sont pour ceux qui sont violents
sont très violents les jeunes de 16 ans
callas la police les jeunes de saison
brûlent les voitures
il y en a énormément c'est pour ça que
la majorité pénale à 16 ans c'est pas
une aberration parce qu'un jeune a 16
ans maintenant vu l'immense violence qui
est développé dans cette classe d'âge
si un jeune c'est qu'il n'aura rien bien
sûr à retourner d'abord c'est comme si
ces récidivistes non qu'il ait connu
donc s'il est connu des services police
je pratique vendra des étoiles est alors
clair du rhône de luan aussi un autre
aspect qui est très grave et qui vient
de tout ce qu'on a vu là derrière c'est
qu'il y avait plein de gens autour
il ya des pères de famille j'ai mon père
il ya des gens les gens ils se disent
mine de rien même fille de 16 ans
derrière les gens mais voilà si je me
couche devrait avoir 10 d'ailleurs qui
vont arriver là les gens ont peur mais
ça c'est la faute à un problème
eric tout le monde a le même
raisonnement les gens détournent le
regard et parce que on ne sait pas ce
qui peut se passer si l'on peut se
casser la gueule mais bien à raison il
peut sortir un couteau il peut sortir
pire et tout le monde a le même
raisonnement
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est la
réponse ne peut être que pénale ne peut
pas mettre un flic autorités
si vous voulez savoir que ce n'est les
violences il ya juste joaillier geoffroy
le jeune il a fait une caricature
ignoble très belle il a laissé public
mais il est obligé d'avoir avec lui 24
heures sur 24
un garde la fin d'autres sujets on a
maintenant mais je dis ça parce que non
mais non mais cyril ya ça a été tout
temps les choses comme la loi de la
pauvre ça c'est des choses qu'on
entendait paillade sur la violence de la
société
on voit maintenant que je raconte ce
qu'on dit un propos vous fait quelque
chose de plus ou moins bien il est
immédiatement
on lui conseille immédiatement d'avoir
de la sécurité autour de lui il ya 20
ans ce n'était pas le cas alors rokhaya
moi je n'ai juste qu'est ce que je peux
te tutoyer bien sûr il ya une chose qui
est que tu as dit qui m'a vraiment
frappé
tu as dit j'étais habillée normalement
ouais y'a aucun moment aucune tenue qui
autorise quiconque à marie galante et de
quelques manières que ce monsieur et je
trouve que le fait que tu te soit senti
obligé de le préciser
ça montre dans quel état dans quel cd on
vit et quelle pression repose sur les
femmes
aucune femme n'est responsable de ce qui
lui arrive quelle que soit la tenue que
tu as aucune personne n'est pas un
message pour quelqu'un qui lui dit qu'il
est autorisé à te violent clé atteint
les mains
voila voila c'est même sa matrice en
fait d'entendre que tu te soit senti
obligé de préciser c'est un gros caca
nous a raconté il ya un instant qu'elle
avait eu une aventure
voilà un petit peu curieuse la semaine
dernière agathe ou es ce que vous avez
déjà été confronté à des loups voilà des
situations comme ça ou vous jamais comme
loi n'est comme rocha ya certainement
des mecs qui tarde est dans la rue et
qui te monte parce qu'on sortait une
certaine violence sont pas du tout ben
cet été oui j'ai je marchais
tranquillement dans la rue est un mec
donc mais après un appareil trop
connaissent de la télé est donc née à
mais c'est toi même ouais ouais ok bah
tu me donnes ton numéro non mange en
europe et en plus c'est pareil c'est
dans une rue passante donc tous motivés
de marché était tu ne t'arrêtes pas tu
ne fais pas la discussion avec cette
personne donc du coup d'une marché et ce
qui m'a effectivement interpellé c'est
que pour la première fois il ya eu un
contact physique ce qui ne m'était
jamais arrivé avant il m'attrape le bras
pour je me retourne et bien c'est bon tu
peux dès deux bons numéros quand même je
prends pour qui
non je peux pas de numéro et je pense
que j'ai eu de la chance parce que et
après moi je dis ça mais tu viens de
nous raconter que tu avais plein de gens
autour de toi avec sanaryens chaussures
et moi je m'étais dit j'ai eu la chance
de ne pas être seul avec ce même là et
que c'était dans une roue extrêmement
passante et qu'ils avaient dû passage
mais toi donc c'est ce qui était arrivé
il ya une semaine que l'aja garde toi
ton agresseurs avec l âge
je pense qu'il avait un peu plus de 20
ans d'accord alors loin est-ce que tu as
peur maintenant pour s comment tu te
sens aujourd'hui sors de chez toi est-ce
que ça fait appréhender autrement la rue
les gens que tu croises alors ben en
fait j'essaye d'avoir eu la même
attitude qu'avant parce que dans tous
les cas bas j'ai une attitude qui change
ou non ça fera pas changer le monde qui
est autour de moi mais c'est vrai que
j'ai adopté des réflexes que j'avais pas
avant comme serré la main très forts de
mon copain quand passe à côté d'un
groupe de jeunes ou alors tourné très
rapidement la tête quand j'entends un
scooter ou des choses comme ça c'est
vrai que j'ai des réflexes que j'avais
pas vu avant et c'est ça montre qu'il ya
quand même au fond - une crainte qui
acquit et qui a traumatisé
bah oui ça fait comme un traumatisme
d'ailleurs des deux plus jeunes souvent
des hits été aussi psychologique
ajoutez au physique parce que ce type
d'agression c'est un très grand
traumatisme qui fait qu'effectivement il
faut du temps pour essayer d'oublier de
panser ses plaies
ce n'est pas un facteur aggravant son
intention tu es prise en charge ces
voiliers physiquement oui ça ça a été
bien leur espace est très entourée luan
partie alors là donc tu attend des
nouvelles de la police qui va dire s'ils
ont interpellé ou pas avec l'agresseur
tu as ça ça tangue wassa de peut-être
pouvoir être d'être confronté à lui ou
de que l'histoire continue parce que
comme disait bruno pomart et n'a
beaucoup aussi
qui sont ceux qui subissent des gaz
agression qui porte pas plainte après
parce qu'ils disent je vais rentrer dans
un système où j'ai peur que ça se
reproduise
j'ai peur de me retrouver en face de mon
agresseur j'ai horreur d'être la
télévision c'est très courageux mais
bien sûr très bien aussi assureurs qui
dès qu'ils te reconnaissent qu'ils peu
loin ça t'apprend pas tout ça parce que
j'ai pas envie qu'on regarde en disant
t'es quoi je sais quoi juger juste envie
que mon regard donc me disent tu es
libre en fête c'est libre de faire ce
que tu veux de bouger comme tu veux de
marché comme tu veux et moi j'ai pas
peur de le confronter j'ai pas peur de
me regarder dans le blanc des yeux
j'ai pas peur de regarder dans le blanc
des yeux lui dire la ta foi remake
nateur là tu as fait n'importe quoi et
je veux que tu payes pour ce que tu as
fait et fils irait jusqu'au bout quoi
peut dire loisne
merci le regrette vraiment qu'il va je
pose servir d'autres personnes qui nous
regardent et luan c'était bas j'ai envie
de te dire tu as raison tu allais à
cette notion de liberté elle est très
importante et elle eu raison le signaler